there was a kid a minor on the red
carpet watching Kanye West's wife do
this at the
Grammys first Kanye is deciding that
maybe he wants to start a company and
then it looks like he might have brought
to real life with bringing his wife
naked to the Grammys like naked like
seriously naked we got a blurred in this
video but she pretty much just took her
coat off and was like a dress that was
skin tight that was full-on Rev
see through like you could see this you
could see this it was everything okay
let's take a look at the clip did Kanye
West and Bianca sori get kicked out of
the 2025 gramys amid reports that the
couple was asked to leave the music
award show after their shocking red
carpet appearance E news has learned
that's not true Kanye a nominee this
year up for best rap song Rather opted
to walk the carpet then got in his car
and left in case you missed it he and
Bianca shocked everybody when they posed
for photogs she took off her fur coat
and revealed a skintight piece of
completely sheer fabric that appeared to
show her naked body
underneath it's almost like they don't
have any shame at
all yeah I mean he was literally
standing there like he was pimping her
or something it was really weird just
stood there too so it's not like a dress
that has the same skin tone as her body
it was literally it was her skin oh my
oh wow Keith I just I don't know how you
don't get arrested yeah I mean in other
contexts in other
places you go to jail yeah it's public
indecency so how do you not get arrested
for That Celebrity uh privilege
I I didn't I don't understand yeah so
here's another one where they talked
about uh what Kanye actually said to her
[Music]
a I don't understand what the statement
is I mean if he shows up and he tells
her to take her coat off and reveal
she's not clothed essentially what and
then leaves like what I mean you're
there for the cameras that's it wanted
to recreate an album was that his own
album that was his
album yeah yeah it's hard it's hard to
tell why these people do what they do I
mean you get you get spoken about in the
news and it's like you know even bad
press can generate that's the only
reason I can think of is just they want
the attention like oh people are
forgetting about me well let me bring my
wife naked to the public maybe they
remember yeah it it is kind of a sad
thing like can you imagine that being
your daughter or your mom or someone
that you know like that that person
right there has a mom and a
dad hopefully D but you know it's like I
I have a daughter and and thinking of
her someday doing something ridiculous
like this it it it's actually saddens me
you know the Bible does talk about that
this will happen in the last days that
these things will show up 2 Timothy 32
five says for men will be lovers of
themselves lovers of money boasters
proud blasphemers disobedient to parents
unthankful Unholy unloving unforgiving
slanderers without self-control brutal
despises of good traitors headstrong huy
lovers of pleasure rather than lovers of
God having a form of godliness but
denying its power and from such people
turn away it's interesting that Kanye RS
claimed to be a Christian yeah I mean
what happened if that Jesus is King
right now that's nowhere to be found and
now it's you know starting a company and
this kind of stuff you know by their
fruits you will know them right I mean
that's why anybody can profess to be a
Christian yeah but does their life
reflect that exactly it it's it's sad
because you know the Bible also talks
about that our body is the Temple of the
Holy Spirit 1 Corinthians 6:19 through2
says do you not know that your body is a
temple of the Holy Spirit who's in you
whom you have from God and you are not
your own for you were bought with the
price therefore glorify God in your body
and your spirit which are Gods you know
God paid the price for everybody right
he paid the price for them and and it's
really sad to see how Kanye was once
assumedly allegedly coming toward Christ
and now is just doing the absolute
opposite this debaucherous stuff to kind
of slap God in the face I think when you
when you read the story in in the Garden
of Eden when and Eve fell and it was
like the first thing that they
recognized was they're they were naked
and they wanted to hide from God right
and uh you know here in this this far
down the timeline almost at the at at
the end of the world it's like we know
that nakedness causes shame but it's
like they're trying to rewrite that like
don't be shameful about this bear it all
like the devil's trying to constantly
put this like you know you can just you
can take it off take it off take more
off and the Bible says in Revelation 16
it talks about like you know don't be
found that you're going to be naked be
clothed and covered with with Christ
righteousness that's right and you can
just see that the the the the world is
trying to reorientate our nakedness MH
yeah Satan is the one in the Bible
that's always pointing that out and
always trying to uncover our shame from
a a spiritual perspective you know and
God is the one that's always trying to
cover us up m mhm you know let me put my
robe of righteousness around you like
you said you know The Mercy Seat was a
covering MH and and so that's that's
God's that's just his way is to is to
cover us to protect us to Shield us to
you know not make everything known about
us and that's a very powerful thought
because God is not here
to expose you I guess so to speak he's
he's closer than that you know it's like
a really good friend MH and he doesn't
just like reveal all the nasty things
about you Felipe or you know or myself
it's interesting that you bring that up
that God wants to cover us because Jesus
was uncovered on the cross you know he's
often portrayed with a linen cloth that
was not the case not the case he was
naked everything was being shown to
everybody I think traditionally on the
cross there was a spike that was
sticking off the cross that was
literally you were you were seating on
sitting on a spike really and so when
you would have to raise yourself up I
mean it was extremely excruciatingly
painful to take a breath and then you
would relax into it just to try to get a
breath and so you were constantly doing
this type of emotion I it's the worst
pain that you could probably ever
inflict something and it's like we
deserved that but Jesus then says I took
that place for you so that you don't
have to go through it but it's like when
we reveal ourselves like this
it's like we are embracing the old
nature the the sinful nature yeah and
the temple was a very Sacred Space I
mean he didn't just do anything in that
that's why Jesus you find him upset that
all this Commerce is going on in the
temple in his day and he's like this is
not what the purpose of the temple is
right and likening our bodies to that
you know a place that God is supposed to
inhabit really shows how God views Us
and how we should be portrayed to the
outside world it's supposed to be a
beautiful place yeah I mean uh God said
build me a sanctuary that I might abide
with my people right dwell among you
yeah all among you which means we're
supposed to have God living in us and if
he's living in us he's not going to live
in like a dirty house right we should
act yeah like he is living in us and
like this like like you were saying
Scotty uh the shame that Jesus was going
through when he was at the cross and
it's like he went through that that so
we
shouldn't uh go through it so we
wouldn't need to but some people just
take that as like oh well I don't care I
go anyways and then we have celebrities
going like that just showing out like
that and claiming to be Christians what
does that do to people who you know are
struggling with their faith or with
people who are trying to find reasons to
not become Christians or even want to
become Christians and see stuff like
that you know in its right context God
created the attraction from a male to a
female right we we are naturally drawn
to nakedness we like it right but in the
context of being married you think about
the priest you brought up the sanctuary
the priest was only allowed in that
inner room right I mean that's kind of
an interesting parallel that in a
marriage should only be that husband
that's allowed in there that sees that
part of his wife and um here it's like
you're exposed for the whole world to
see that you shouldn't considering all
these things we've just discussed uh
have you guys heard of Taylor Alisia
YouTube yeah she on
created in indecent materials for
patreon and sold it to people not only
fans but on patreon and she became a
Christian and now she speaks very highly
of of Christian modesty especially in in
women and I really appreciate this clip
from her uh she's given us a shout out a
couple times so thank you Taylor uh
shout out back at you in this video but
yeah I really app appreciate this video
that she made so let's take a
look the 1950s showed us how influential
those that are in the Lim light can be
on fashion choices celebrities also set
the stage for women's fashion many
models and actresses were seen as the
very definition of beauty and were
followed after then came the sexual
revolution in the 1960s which we have
talked about so much on this channel
truthfully after studying this
revolution so much this is where America
Chang changed forever when it would
never be the same being that the birth
control pill was introduced it allowed
women to control their fertility making
it that they can have as many sexual
partners as they wanted with a lower
risk of pregnancy which I believe is a
very large reason why marriage rates
have been in a long decline ever since
in the 1970s crop tops became a symbol
of the feminist movement and were worn
as a statement of Liberation and
empowerment I had no idea that this was
the story behind the crop top this
movement led the 1980s to be all about
power responding to the times designers
like e St laon crafted suits and skirt
suits that wore like armor shoulders
were exaggerated and padded double
breasted Silhouettes which made a figure
Loom larger than it was bold's colors
differentiated the look from traditional
men's suits so it looks like this was
the first time where men's fashion
entered into women's fashion the 1990s
clothing became even less 2000s even
less and fast forward to 2012 I guess
this still wasn't enough nakedness for
everybody because there was a movement
control the flow of nudity and violence
into our theaters our sexuality has been
taken away from us and is essentially
being sold back to us you honestly
believe that we can change the laws in
this country you need to go really big
National publicity stunts viral camp
this movement challenged the double
standard that allows men to go shirtless
while often penalizing women for showing
their
thankfully that failed and we don't have
women walking around with their shirts
off but even though things didn't go in
that direction we ended up going a
different route the Kardashians have
played I'd argue the most vital role in
leading women's fashion wearing outfits
that most women probably would have
never even dared to wear until they
watched this show also being the many
female rap artists like cardi B and Ice
spice who are now leading this next
Generation somewhere I don't know where
we're going to find out only time will
tell the influence of celebrities though
like I don't know is there's just you
know there are so many celebrities who
act like dudes who just act have this
behavior of like yo what's up bro I'm
going to you know and and then you know
she's mentioning the clothing and how
things are changing and I think it's an
agenda I really think it's an agenda
yeah when when a lot of these rap stars
started coming out with some of the
these really provocative um I mean I I I
can remember a few years ago one of them
um did an entire like dance series on
the rap video not a piece of clothing on
the entire group of dancers behind them
was Stark naked and I was just like why
why would you do that like for what
reason would you ever think that that's
okay and it's like they are they're
they're just throwing this out there and
you break down social norms and you know
things change as you can see clearly in
all these videos it's like you know you
just keep messing with it until pretty
much people aren't ashamed by it and
they'll go and celebrate it I think
that's the idea they want to desensitize
everyone make it more normal I mean
before uh well I'm fairly young gen Z I
guess you can say but I I heard of
movies in the past you couldn't say
certain words before and now everything
is you know any word is free now and I
believe the same was with how much you
could show on somebody's body uh nudity
was highly censored and now you know
it's not hard to find a PG-13 movie that
will have a scene yeah 13 years old
you're not supposed to be seeing that
stuff other than you know your parents
teaching you biology you know ratings
creep yeah I mean it's just it's just
super common right now I don't remember
what the actual amount of images an
adolescent sees it was really high I
mean I think in the 60s there was a
certain number and then it was like
doubling by the 70s and 80s and then it
was like tripling quadrupling and like
what we see today is Thousands ands of
images the the series um the the show
Game of Thrones when it came out people
were complaining that every 30 minutes
there was a scene I know on it and I
mean every single actress on there has
gone naked for at least one scene and
apparently that wasn't common but no
nobody really talks about it have you
guys heard of Nicholas Sparks do you
guys know who he is MHM yeah like the
notebook yeah so he's I think he's the
author of the books and then they turn
into a bunch of them into movies The
Notebook um The Lucky One The Lucky One
um yeah there's one with Miley Cyrus
anyway they're all kind of the same but
I honestly think that it's straight
up movie style
women's I mean why do you have to sit
down and watch two people have and like
it's straight up soft for women but it's
on the movie screen mhm it's I've been
on many airplanes and you know you can
see what everybody's watching and people
watch terrible things it's like oh my
there's there's kids on this plane it
also doesn't help that places like
Netflix you know independent Studies
have shown that they push that mature
content to teenage audiences doesn't
surprise me doesn't surprise me so she
brought up something about um how women
really start dressing like men then the
Bible has something to say about it
Deuteronomy 22:5 a woman shall not wear
anything that pertains to to a man nor
shall a man put on a woman's garment for
all who do so are an Abomination to the
Lord your God it's interesting she was
talking about the the suits and stuff
and the women like with the broad
shoulders I'm like man we progress to
some worse stuff really quick but I want
to talk about the value that we have in
God right I I mentioned earlier we are
created in His image Genesis 1:27 says
so God created man in his own image an
image of God he created him male and
female he created them um and then it
says in Isaiah 43:4 and7 since you were
precious in my sight you have been
honored and I have loved you therefore I
will give men for you and people for
your life everyone who is called by my
name whom I have created for my glory I
have formed him yes I have made him so I
think when we realize as Christians that
we Are Made In His Image we realize
that's where our value is and you know
this morning morning I went to the gym
um and I saw a female there who was with
another guy they were clearly into each
other who was wearing yoga pant but they
were literally the the length of her
underwear and I wasn't thinking about
this in any judgmental way or anything I
just thought I was praying for her I was
like Lord help her to see the value she
has in you that there is no need for us
to show ourselves publicly openly like
our body parts like that but I was just
praying for her Lord help her to see
that you love her and you've made her
and and yes uh um I think God made
everyone's bodies you know beautiful he
made us in His
image but that there's something
beautiful about keeping that for
marriage you know keeping that for the
spouse and and having such value but
it's all in God if that makes sense MH
MH I think in the beginning um you know
talks about um in Genesis where there
was like precious stones all over the
ground right and um in the
beginning you know God could have made
man out of precious stones he could have
adorned them but he didn't MH you know
and I think that they Heaven had just
gone through this experience of Lucifer
being or you know designed with all
sorts of precious stones um you know he
was a a very shiny creation if you would
and and it's not that God does not like
those things it's just that when he came
to man he wanted to show that our value
was not in the external right and that
the value is really what's what's inside
of our characters and so that object
lesson is is really I think what God is
trying to Humble us and give us a very
you know yeah humble plain like look
instead of you know make making people
focus on things that are not part of of
your character you know yeah I
appreciate you bring that up because uh
1 Peter 33-4 also says do not let your
adorin be merely outward arranging the
hair wearing gold or putting on fine
apparel rather let it be the hidden
person of the heart with The
Incorruptible beauty of a gentle and
quiet Spirit which is very precious at
the sight of God yeah I don't think it's
that God doesn't like precious stones I
mean the city of the city of Jerusalem
is on 12 foundations of stones right you
know he put stones on the ephod of the
priest like he he likes streets of gold
he likes these things it's not like he
doesn't like people to you know dress up
decently or anything like that I mean
the Bible is full of examples of people
who the Bible says they were good-look
yeah right Saul was goodlook Rachel was
goodlooking you know was full of those
yeah but not to let that outward thing
be the thing that people are attracted
to exactly yeah so that when people see
us really we want them to see Jesus
because of your your acts your loving
kindness your the fruits of the spirit
that are in you and they ging glory to
God instead of you because God knows
that as soon as we start you know
adorning ourselves parading around like
a peacock and just like look at me it's
self-destructing because selfishness
destroys you right yeah to reinforce
that point it says in 1 Peter 2:9 in
like manner also that the women Adorn
themselves in modest apparel with
propriety and moderation not with
braided hair or gold or pearls or costly
clothing but which is proper for women
professing godliness and good works mhm
yeah this kind of a Greek construct that
we tend to
Value the external pretty things more
than the internal things of value yeah
and again it's not it's not that those
things aren't to be admired or valued
it's just not more so than the person or
who somebody is yeah it's not that God
wants to make his creation ugly because
he doesn't like goodlooking things like
you know he he he made Lucifer one of
the most
beautiful angels but because of his
Beauty it it broke him down yeah and and
you know I've heard people take it this
Versed and say well can I not braid my
hair then so like you can put it in a
ponytail but you can't braid it I don't
think that's what the verse is saying
because in in the the previous one first
Peter it says do not let your nor would
be merely outward right like so don't
put the emphasis on there but I don't
think it's saying you shall not braid
your hair like like you you can like I
said you can put a ponytail but not this
that's not the point the point is don't
put it on display to attract attention
to yourself exactly yes it's about the
heart the heart is what God is after and
not the outward appearance when these
celebrities are going on the red carpet
nobody ever thinks man she looks really
nice doesn't she I bet she has a great
personality yeah there's all the fashion
and stuff that's commented but if you
read a lot of reports of common people
that have interactions with celebrity or
people that have worked with them
there's not a lot of favorable reports
out there you know they complain about
how these people are not very nice to
them or don't treat them like a human
being or this one's a diva you know so
they look nice they dress nice but
what's on the inside and and I'm not
saying everybody I I can't speak for
everybody I mean there's there's people
who have good reputation I think K
Reeves is one of those that's known to
be like very generous with people and
I'm sure there's there's ones that are
out there that are like that yeah but it
does show you that I I I believe
Hollywood is not from God and it shows
you where it tends to go including in
the outward appearance right and and in
the fruits that are sometimes frequently
not seen versus what God wants from us
yeah it's very self-exalting and and I
think when we get to the end of History
we're going to look back and see these
people that lived very humble very
simple lives that didn't have these
things weren't clothed with these things
but they were beautiful people who led
many to Christ amen and when you make
that contrast you know it's like the
contrast that you see in in Revelation
18 Babylon this this great Empire with
all its riches and the merchants and
everything in contrast with God's people
and it's it's a huge contrast but it's
mostly about what they're like yeah
Isaiah 61:10 says I will greatly rejoice
in the Lord my soul shall be joyful in
my god he has clothed me with the
garments of Salvation he has covered me
with the robe of righteousness amen so I
really appreciate what you said earlier
about that God always wants to cover us
maybe it was Keith he wants to cover us
he wants to not show our nakedness and
because that is a reference back to sin
of living that previous life and once
we've given our lives to Christ he wants
to cover us he wants to us to be clothed
with his righteousness and his salvation
and I I I don't want to just come out
here and say well you shouldn't wear
this or you shouldn't wear that or you
should wear this or that I think what
the point is that once Christ is in our
heart you know we should allow the Holy
Spirit to convict us and say you know
maybe I should not do this and maybe I
should not take that piece of clothing
anymore and it's a journey you know
there's been times when I thought to
myself you maybe I should toss that one
for now um but I the point is that
Christ wants us to see our value in him
and what he's done for us and his
salvation and I think that when we
receive that salvation it starts to
reflect in our appearance and this
applies to both men and women yeah you
know you you have to think of too um
Jesus saying that you know if you lust
after a woman you're committing adultery
with her in your heart but but that can
also happen with men you know I me I
mean men can sit there and focus on
their bodies absolutely and display
their bodies in a way that that will
make a stumbling block for women so you
know this is kind of a two-way street
not just pointing the finger at women
men deal with the same sort of thing as
well and also men um you know can also
like you said want to point to their
appearance not just being a stumbling
block for other women but being a
stumbling block for people to see Christ
in you MH you know did you ever read The
Scarlet Letter yeah way back I had to
read it in high school
like Nathaniel Hawthorne and it's this
book about a a woman who commits
adultery and so then she has to
wear a an A and I think it's red MH and
I don't remember what kind of community
she was in if it was Puritan or Quaker
what have you but it was an emblem of
Shame like this is what you did and
everybody's going to know it and
whenever she went out in public or
interacted with people that was always
there and it's a beautiful contrast to
see that God is Not branding us with a
Scarlet Letter he's promising to wash
away our sins and make us clean M and
cover us so that we're not exposed to
the
world Amen that's what we need to do
that's be covered by Jesus and the white
robe of his righteousness and his
salvation amen well thank you guys so
much for watching um thank you guys for
tuning in if you uh have a thought make
sure you drop it in the comments below
and make sure you hit like And subscribe
you got plenty more videos coming out
for you every single week if you want to
support our ministry you can do so by
going to
ls. or
patreon.com Studios or speaking of
clothing you can shop at our Christian
apparel company called lightwear you get
baby Keys hoodie reverse the curse or
you can get the Three Angels t-shirt on
our website which is uh kind of like a a
a hint at the Adidas logos a probably a
most popular t-shirt so make sure you
grab one of those uh and otherwise make
sure you stay tuned this week got a lot
more videos coming out and we'll see you
next time on LD live
[Music]